yasuo has his work cut out for him I'm
gonna I'm gonna try not to open the root
for my boy
hutch I'm not I'm not with anyone but
I'm deaf if I was coaching I've had a
lot going on outside of the chess event
this week so I didn't get involved in
the coaching thanks to you and everyone
else for holding that down but if I was
coaching hutch would have been one of
the guys I I hope to add to Team Danny
so who knows yes that would have made a
lot of sense given your guys's history
and we have take off Danny the game is
about to get started we do its Shaun
Hutchinson on the move as he as he goes
now d4 dad came from what Melos dad I'm
not sure how Yasuo got this name yeah so
his room is um interesting it looks like
a comfy bed spread yeah it's nice it's a
giant bed almost as big as his entire
room there yeah and we see him setting
up a slob defense here and whoa f5 is
pretty bold what's your take on this Dan
yeah what's a stone well yeah I jump
back on that because that's a that is an
aggressive move and the fact that he
played it quickly tells me it's it's
prep so it's it's not necessarily bad
everyone will quickly describe it before
we listen in it's not a bad move but
it's very risky whenever you open up the
light scores towards your King and
that's gonna be the case whether the
King stays put or goes over here if
hutch can find the right idea which
would be to pry open the light squares
make a breakthrough in the center
there's a lot of potential problems when
you make that kind of aggressive
assertion early on but let's let's
listen in to Yasuo and see what he's
thinking about the position because
we've got him on board and see if he's
describing to pin the the night I attack
pawn I attack this piece that's some
ideas but I think before I do any of
that bull I need to just focus on
developing so clearly my Queens under
attack here so what's the most
comfortable position for my Queen to be
in I guess to me did I just retreat my
queen defensively like the exact same
way or when I want to position my queen
obviously this line is completely it's
done so I think I want to put it like
right here maybe to just go here or I
can just put my queen here and over the
problem with that is then I won't be
able to castle so I'm gonna put my Queen
over here actually but as you
defenses or attacks to my queen I don't
think so I think Queen here is good
because I've these ideas I've these
ideas have I have everything for my
queen here so this is fine I want to get
my night out and then I want to end up
castling here that's my goal Wow it's
it's not just that his ideas are logical
like the speed and repetition there how
quickly can I talk about key is this
piece I this move yeah I mean this is
one of the things that I was most
impressed with him as well he doesn't
dumb move here then I think I can
possibly I've tricks okay let's move my
knight here Oh
[Music]
because if takes takes and then I'm
hitting both pieces the only way he
doesn't really lose a piece now is if he
retreats his piece but then I have a
really nice square for my knight here
the whole time or he or he takes with
Bishop and then I'm trading Bishop for
Knight which i think is worth in my
opinion so I like this so far this is
what I practice is what I prepared for I
was in my boy hutch might be in trouble
here for a guy that's how is this guy
rated 865 right yes we still have his
audio honoree no he's gone now it's just
us your thoughts on that this is what
blew me away also when he had been
talking like this during our lesson I
thought okay this guy has been you know
playing chess as a kid or something and
then I asked him how long he played for
he said three weeks and you know I
decided I'm done playing chess Wow he
blew me away with that no I'm not
kidding jokes aside and I do you think
um of people I think that we're over
hyping it but the truth is and white is
still better here but his structural
understanding of kind of what to do
putting the knight on in the center
early just knowing what he needs to do
to get castle he's and this is this is
kind of the ideal reasons you play a5
earlier everyone I was highlighting the
potential drawbacks on the last verse
but if you can get this kind of space
rolling you might have g5 in chief or
and bring more pieces to this side of
the board this is a you know a very
double-edged position Black has
sacrificed the dark squares himself but
has a real stranglehold and the thing
about the way he's describing alexandra
is like he sounded experienced beyond
865 so it's not even about the rating
right it's like the the positional way
describe that I was very impressed with
that yeah exactly and he himself said he
thinks he is
higher rated in reality than his actual
chest comm yellow and I see Gotham chess
in the chat who also helped coach him
and it's he's saying that this was part
of his prep and you can also tell by how
quickly he's played until now that he's
very very familiar maybe this is the
point where he's out of opening theory
huh well he's uh maybe he's smurfing it
maybe he really is secretly much higher
rated that he's telling all of us and
this whole thing is like my twist ending
two rips it off it's not Yasuo it's
Magnus Carlsen no I'm kidding but I mean
final rimmel magnet Oh Oh Magnus doesn't
play on it's just not common for a god
can't be that ending sorry so he rips it
off it's yun upon these sheep my bad
everyone but
anyway okay Hutch castles I was kind of
hoping that Hutch might delay it a
little bit and try to deal with the
night meaning maybe move the night from
f3 to try to poke the pony never poke
the pony at home everyone that can be
very dangerous but if you can do it
safely under adult supervision you can
you can maybe get rid of that night poke
the pony all right that we are learning
we're learning from from dad wrench no
animals no animals were harmed during
that reference do not worry em fair
enough it looks like Yasuo is trying to
close up the position he moved b5 and it
really Temps white into playing before
here do you think a close position is in
his favor given that he's still the
underdog here yeah because I think that
he's I think he's following some sort of
advice and maybe levy will take credit
for this that's Gotham chess in the chat
uh I think the here's the advice that
would be given to someone on a high
level about the structure of what they
would say is white has a big space
advantage over here and they're gonna
attack over here so if you can stop that
attack if you can close it up that
allows you to focus on this side of the
board which has already been led by the
F Mullen the whole dutch idea that he
went for so I don't even know that b5 is
the best move I don't think it was but I
think that his high level ideas are
being made clear here I think he clearly
understands that if he can somehow lock
it up if he can lock up this side of the
board he knows he has the potential for
remaining attack and here we go that's
what rook f6 is all about he's gonna do
so so I'm impressed again with yahwah's
approach even if it's not objectively
the best for black right and speaking
about objectively the best it is
intimidating for hutch that he's
bringing his rook here but if you try to
look in terms of follow up something
like rook h6
I mean it's putting pressure on h2 but
h2 is defended and Yasuo cannot bring
his Queen into the game so there kind of
ghost threats well right now right but
one of the ideas is if the structure
remains and white hasn't done anything
to undermine it this is not what I was
highlighting earlier white really wanted
e4 so if you don't do anything the way
the knight gets kicked is with a move
like g5 and g4 coming I mean just to
show everybody how dangerous this is if
you don't make high level threats fast
at some point g5 and g4 come in and when
this night has to move here comes these
covered things and the the maining
attack for black would be very real so
again that takes a little bit of
cooperation white didn't play the best
moves but just showing where this game
could go and that's what Yasuo wants
look at the time
yeah hutches hutch is sitting here and I
think you always see that when you think
there's about to have you're about to be
attacked on the kingside so this is a
critical position for him he plays a
great move 95 is really nice here I just
wonder how he's gonna react once yeah so
continues pushing his pawns on the
inside so I was real proud of hutch
there I gave the sammy sosa yeah 95 is a
great move because not only does it
execute the dark squares which are the
biggest problem with whites on structure
but also it opens up the idea I've been
calling for for a while the moment white
gets f3 and E for the game changes here
if black does nothing and and this trade
starts happening white will just blow
things open and this King will actually
be the weaker King because of all the
light squares that were exposed long ago
and well we see rook h6 plate so this is
what I was a little bit afraid of for
black because there's no good follow up
after this threat okay I guess Queen h4
is a little bit scary but it's a very
easy threat to take care of it seems
like he's going for one move tricks but
if hutch sees them then he's much better
long-term yeah but it's a practical try
you got to give Yasuo credit when you're
the underdog right if you go for a
mating attack sometimes that can scare
the opponent because the truth is black
has nothing here you're totally right if
white plays f3 and and black goes for
this white could even just take the
knight and this is this is a check but
that might end up being all it is you're
down a piece so but but it's just hutch
have the guts to go for this right this
is kind of scary to let your opponent
get an attack like that and I think
that's what Oh
because now he's gonna let ya so take
back with a tempo I bet he's gonna play
Queen h4 here I think he's just going in
for the kill
yeah he's got you
unfortunately it for Yasuo it could
probably just be stopped in one move and
what are you got nothing right and then
he's gonna realize that he hasn't
developed any of his Queen side bishops
sorry Queen side pieces the rook the
knight the bishop and once his attack
has stopped he's behind in development
and he has less control in the center
because of the knight on e5 last time I
neglected development this bad my
abusive Russ says Russian alcoholic
chess coach came up and just threw all
the pieces on the board and said you
don't need
I'm still a baby Danny we can talk about
this after if you don't need to pee okay
let's listen in to Yasuo get me off
get me off cam here so this is really
dangerous area for him he if he blunders
this somehow he might lose the game okay
see he just caught it but now what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna move my knight up
if trades I take with my bishop I think
so I can get my bishop activated okay
now he's attacking my rook I can move my
rook here to this file take on the G
file now I want to take on the G file or
do I want to go here he'll probably
smoove pawn up so it's not gonna be good
for me
let's I don't know about you everything
I suddenly have the desire that's just
to refinance my mortgage while drinking
an energy great because I'm attacking
and I'm attacking is maybe I don't know
mate I could go for like a cobra know
why there's suddenly in my head that I
might want to do that and I'm thinking
that thing I'm finding a pretty good
game so far I'm not playing too poorly
actually rather he's playing good moves
obviously if you have much higher rated
than me like he has a lot more
experience with chess than I do I need
to get this piece out there do I go here
but that's just gonna give him an
opportunity to like waste my move so I
don't really like that too much but I
have no other way to move that piece and
I have no way to develop this and I also
that means I have no way to develop my
rook so I think it's actually just worth
to go here and look for a trade because
if he trades and I just take with rook
Frey worth for me I could also look to
take pawn and then if he ever takes back
but I'll probably check back with Bishop
talk superfast yeah interesting what do
I want to do here anything that's the
pot calling the kettle black here what
does he have I don't see any real
threats he has he'll most likely go back
here and then I can take this or he'll
just perma stay there I think he might
just stay there for mistake could I
write that down to use with legal
because if he takes for me I mean I'm
trying to keep up with both of you Danny
he's just thinking so fast I could use
some perma State guys I want to look at
chat to see the fog champs I'm once
again just gonna say don't cheat
all right do we have a mutant
reiterating I haven't taken anything
from Jim still have we still his Audion
today we're gonna mute him let's mute
and talk a little bit about
what just happened because
the attack here but it looks like hutch
is defended really well right didn't
didn't blink an eye yeah and one thing
he was saying is hutch is the more
experienced players so yeah so
understood that he had to develop his
pieces he saw that his rook was under
attack but it seems like he's just
getting slowly outplayed here not making
any specific mistakes but just slightly
the worst moves in his opponent
agreed and one of the risks of blacks
position when you go all-in with an idea
like this you bring your rook over to a
very committed side of the board rooks
do much better when they're connected
when they're talking and and their
long-range powerful pieces so you can do
a lot when that's the case but now
blacks piece is being disconnected you
start spying F takes e4 and you you know
blow open the cannon here um if xqc were
here he'd call it like I don't know
I don't know I'd call it it's hard to
understand excuses love your brilliance
Danny so don't worry about it don't try
by the way bishop eh is created that
possibility he took yeah sumo might be
about to blunder mate oh if he moves his
night yeah that's don't take with the
night yeah so he's got to take with the
pawn here but not only that Alexandra if
he takes the Queen
hashtag boat his gambit a good boat ends
game but that's what I like to see
Queenie for chat you can't take the
Queen it's matin baked he sees it though
he sees it I'm telling you
Yasuo is sharp with the tactics he's got
arrows on f8 he knows what's happening I
think he knows what's happening but it
might be too late right hutch spotted it
instantly so heads-up play to recognize
the rook on doing its own defensive f8
to immediately take and open up the F
file if he sees Bishop g6 I'm gifting
him 5 subs chat you heard it here if he
plays Bishop g6 he's picked up the wall
I go do it awesome by the way he's still
losing but great job with the 5 subs
though alright that was awesome that was
awesome the 5 simcha that's why I don't
say things like that but let's we're
gonna we'll wait for the sub gift yeah I
sent them in that's awesome probably
they're rollin you know basically done
mo now they are they're rolling in over
the board they're real killer such an
impressive move to see because it
defends the f8 square the pawn and it
develops a piece it's a triple whammy I
mean she deserves five for that
I'm sure his time I'm sure his chat will
uh will tell him that they were gifted
by you that was pretty awesome way to go
good call
alright well like I said unfortunately
it's still trouble for black but but
you're right it was a huge move the rook
defense the checkmate the knight is
suddenly free for business again so
after you asked about takes he should
probably take with the pawn and then you
could even put the knight back on he
foreign and
you know blacks it okay shape here yeah
and the time situation is pretty close
also I've seen yeah so planner time
pressure and he's quite fast cuz he
mostly just plays five minutes what have
you seen with hutch okay yeah hutch is
down one time and that's that's
historically been would have hutches
problems by the way back when I was
touches adopted chess coach he sometimes
overthinks things and gets himself under
time pressure so Wendy twos a good move
in a quick one it's a double defense of
b4 and III and actually opens up the
idea of playing efore to kick the night
again poke the pony poke the pony I
didn't think I'd hear that sentence once
in my life and now I've heard it twice
in two hours Thank You Danny you're
welcome you're welcome
rookie eight so he's he's defending the
pawn I mean a little bit of over
protection there but he didn't really
have him he must have missed that threat
yeah
hutch that's why hutch is 1450 that's
why he's he's one of the favorites to
maybe win this whole event and after
this victory will pretty much clinch
first in his bracket in his quad yeah I
guess in turr like Queen g3 is kind of a
sneaky move so he can at least take back
with his queen he'll only be down and
exchange those and no position is closed
so he still has chances but he really
doesn't want to loo in his pawn
structure here so you're saying there's
a chance Lloyd Christmas yeah there's a
chance Lloyd Christmas it's dumb and
Dumberer reference oh I remember that no
I actually I do know that reference or
just where you're like oh you're sold no
no I thought that was the reference you
were making also I just didn't remember
that was the lady's name yeah well it's
Jim Carrey's name a long story I know it
was when the girl told him there's a
very small jug of lady's name the lady's
name is Mary Swanson Mary Swanson but
it's actually not nice nevermind all
right by the way yasuo finds your idea
it was a strong one
and you're right he's definitely made
this tough and given the ensuing time
scramble they say where there's a night
there's a way when you have time
pressure if you have a night it's one of
the trickiest P no one's ever said that
is that what you're saying no III think
I haven't heard it as a rhyme but you're
the dr. Seuss of chess so I understand
why why you wrapped it up for us like
that but it's true Forks are harder to
see in time pressure
yeah and the nights are just pesky jokes
aside they really I mean geometrically
they move differently and so there are a
lot of blunders that happened with
nights under time pressure and I it's
the most differently from any other
piece so it does make sense I don't like
his e5 decision if he's down material he
should try to keep the position as close
as possible right well especially cuz
it's fool's gold you play e5 and you're
bluffing if white takes the pawn you
can't actually take back right cuz it's
checkmate oh but but hutch missed it
still he has this nice move that is
pinning the night hmm wrong with that is
what's what's the point you take back
and I'm actually liking ya soo those
chances now you know what this is a good
lesson in prophylaxis which is defensive
mindedness for those watching it just
play move like a g6 here if you're a
throw like free some space for the King
not to get checkmated a move by h6
freeze your rook off of the back rank
and now this is just a check thing is I
like h6 a lot it's a movie Ono made into
why did you see did you see much pause
with the beer no no I didn't I was like
really grated listened and I played that
game poorly I played that really poorly
damn that sucks so I tried guys unlucky
I made like two or three big bun there's
that game I tried my heart as though
hey we've all blamed a misclick buddy
we've all been there yes the L magneto
strategy once again the misclick the
misclick nothing like claiming there's a
mouse slit you know it's either the
mouse lip or chats fault that's how you
play chess on Twitch
nobody ever loses because they're bad
ever right no it's true umm anyway I
remember we were talking about it until
King h8 happened I but I rely do find it
kind of ironic that I think the last
chest move we were highlighting is Bri
the back rank Bri the back rank for the
King plate prophylaxis goes a long way
when you go out of your way to prevent
blunders you make a future defensive
move instead he created the net himself
by putting the King on h8 and this is
what they call a back rank checkmate the
king is trapped by his own pieces on the
back rank well one good thing he did
there was illustrate your points so
clearly Danny now more people are going
to want to listen to your coaching
you
we'll be right back
and we are back here now joined by both
players which is pretty awesome first
first time today we have Yasuo and Hutch
with us now first much congratulations
on on the win they're taking the lead
and yeah sooo a great game here thank
you yeah good game to you yeah see ya
thank you now yeah I enjoyed it was fun
honestly pretty good game overall
honestly all the moves you made expect
it studied it no problem but just good
enough yeah I heard you got you got tips
on the Queens gambit from Hikaru
oh yeah Cara gave me some tips early in
the morning because I just you know I
ranted shot and then action I saw a
Levi's Gotham chest in the chat and I
whispered and I was like yo can you give
me some tips on what to do against this
opening like what do you thinks the most
solid play because I think overall from
giving you your comfort since you're
white piece you get you kind of get to
decide what goes on like personally I'm
more comfortable two white pieces so
when I play black I usually just insta
push to d4 I believe like I push my
King's pawn but he told me I think the
Stonewall I think it's called
is like a pretty good like saw defense
and like it'll put you make you a little
more uncomfortable and I honestly liked
it I like the positioning I was in I
just you know is about that is that the
f5 push is that one Stonewall okay yeah
it's like when all my pawns are
connected like a little thank you yeah
well I was gonna say at that point I
figured I would just try to keep your
your LightSquared Bishop as pinned as
possible and try to also with your
knight back there your knight was sort
of trapped there for a while yeah I was
looking for ideas to get my night out it
was just it's error my bishop fell I
actually even talked to Dom just about
it before and he said it was like
perfectly fine it obviously takes more
moves to develop it onto the Kings side
and I actually miss clicked it I think I
pushed it too early I don't think it
really mattered honestly too much but I
forgot when I even missed clicked it
honestly but I yeah I tried getting it
out there just took like 17 moves
unfortunately what were you gonna say
Danny I well I was I was gonna say that
um you guys both actually had very solid
approaches just from the Dutch for hutch
you not even knowing that it really was
the Dutch and I think that the critical
moment well I want to ask you yes you
know when you played the move b5 was
this kind of a tip you were given to
sort of try to close down the Queen side
so that you could focus on your attack
over here on the Kings oh I think the
reason I push that was because I
realized let me think what did I push
that I don't remember let me say no okay
wait okay when I was trying to do is
I'll try to push that and then I was
trying to get my Bishop out onto the a
file to attack his LightSquared Bishop
because I realized mine's a lot less
active than his so I was like okay I
wanted to somehow trade it and I was
looking to push the pawn one more move
both the and then to defend the bishop
and then he just pushed his pawn and
that I couldn't let just close the
hunter said no thank you
did you shake your finger hush when you
played before to the idea did you go no
thank you no I just said lock it lock it
up we're just gonna lock it up I'm gonna
keep that light squared Bishop over
there in the corner and yeah I figured
it was gonna be kind of a slow
positional game at that that's the case
so did you get surprised at all when he
went for the quick rook lift it seemed
that you were taking some time there to
make sure you weren't in trouble um no I
wasn't like well as soon as he pushed it
to f6 I figured that's where he was
heading was that was a h-file but I just
sort of looked at the board and yeah I
was just making sure that I wasn't in
too much trouble because he needed a
little you needed a few more pieces in
order for that to be like a real threat
yeah for me when I when I put it on the
edge file I think just taking that file
and I realized he couldn't really do
much to my rook unless he moved his
knight to pieces and my actual plan was
to move my Queen onto that c7 to attack
the knight and then also look to connect
to the rook I look for a mate somehow
and then I was gonna move the knight
over one piece like move the Knight to
d7 tight push the push the night away
and then also just give myself like a
real nice line but I think you respond
to that by I probably did honestly but
you hear you fine - three he kind of
kind of spied the idea I don't know I
think at that point like I was just I
was getting my rook involved into the
game and I was tryna I'm clearly like
three of my pieces are super undeveloped
right now he's like I had in development
here but that's where I was trying to
like move my bishop like it's like a
little diagonal I feel like swinging it
all across and like somehow it it looked
like it was just gonna take me like zoom
it so many moves so I didn't even want
to do it there yeah oh you guys have
pretty polite chess coaches my my old
Russia
abusive alcoholic chess coach would just
throw all of these pieces off the board
because you weren't using them will do
that to you don't worry the same the
same thing happened in my game my first
game my I didn't move my legs Bishop for
30 moves so yeah like I learned from
that game I'm like okay well that sucked
so let me see if I can do to that guy no
I was I was gonna say you guys both
played super well I mean this was a good
game all around and then you know when
this f3 move was played it was clear you
could kind of kind of figured out the
right idea to sort of pry open the light
squares often in these Dutchess blacks
biggest strength could become their
biggest weakness if you can just start
opening it up because all of these
squares are just like secretly waiting
to be exposed right so f3 was a very
good move to try to start doing that and
I push that with the doubling the rooks
up in mind cuz I figured that they were
gonna be really powerful at that
LightSquared Bishop was gonna be stay
stuck on that uh cc8 square yeah so then
95 I mean yes well when you when you uh
you lost the pawn here you've recovered
very well this was the famous Alexandra
says because you blooded the pawn right
obviously I can't take what the night
cuz a mate and if the pawn takes hutch
could take with the Queen and your
knight is pinned but she said if he
finds Bishop she's six I'm gifting him
five subs and you played it right after
that yeah that was a really good move
didn't that's like when I blundered the
pawn and I was just trying to like
somehow figure out how to you know
recover it and that's actually when I
finally got my life squared it took me a
13 moves like I said to get it out there
finally got it out there finally did
something and then I ain't gonna
blundering my rook right after you know
you don't play like you're writing you
not in this game you played really
really well actually yeah the problem is
I played chess while I play League so
most of the time I have to like resign
my chess games or lose on time because
my league game starts so I think I'm
like closer to a thousand but yeah
definitely a tough game still yeah it's
like hutch had the the slight experience
advantage here but you didn't make any
blunder so it was really slow play where
he was just making slightly better move
by better move okay until your your
checkmate in the end did you most live
or what happened
when you played King AJ okay so I moved
King h8 in mind - like unpin my my night
because I was looking for some type of
idea I was planning on moving my night I
thinked c3 to somehow attack the rook
and like under the pawn on double the
rooks I mean I you know there doubled up
whatever and I should have obviously
pushed the pawn first I just I I come by
and I just forgot that I was under
threat of me the reason I forgot it's
cause I was like oh my rooks defending
and my Kings defending I want some with
my king I was one of the defenders and
she's GG right do you see any um
anything that you would have done
differently from from the whites point
of view here I think instead of Queen
eight - we thought maybe you're gonna
take that pawn on e4 that may have been
a little bit better but it was just a
slight difference his rook is stuck to
the back ring so in some ways you could
have taken I think since you since you
asked I would say I think the only thing
you could have done earlier if I'm going
all the way back was actually here when
you were actually way ahead in the
initiative here and I don't think you've
realized how strong your position was if
you just start like playing a 4 + b5 and
busting open everything on this side of
the board
other than that dude I mean look like
that I was looking at that was one of my
moves but I don't I don't remember what
I decided on instead like if you start
opening this thing up right and they
take and you can just like continue to
bring pieces and push b5 a lot of times
the way to take advantage of this is to
just overwhelm the Queen side with all
of your pieces but what you did was very
solid and ultimately the fact that you
eventually played f3 was a really key
thing to kind of to kind of remember for
the future in these lines to not let
blacks light squares become a
stranglehold so me and hutch but
old-school like like old times when we
used to do jet streams together but yeah
some oh you just said you just said to
talk about your League of Legends
streamed right you play chess in the
middle of your stream sometimes right
and that may be why your chest out calm
rating is so low we were listening you
in on you a lot dude and there's no way
you're an 800 rated chess player like
you are much better than that so maybe
it's time to stop resigning the chest
and just not resigning the league games
okay there's my chess what do you think
we'll look into that you know the league
games are a little harder so I have to
focus a little more on those for sure
but try I tried playing both at the same
time like honestly initially I started
like I was like oh I don't want to
resign this game I need to focus I'd
played the chess game while I'm in the
league game and then turns out I
couldn't do that so I'd end up losing
both games at the same time I was like
it's not worth it I have to sacrifice
one but no thank you for the compliment
yeah I was wondering what do you guys
think I like where do you think I really
like kind of through I was I through the
game when I you know pinned both my
rooks together wouldn't Winnie bishop in
there whatever but besides that what do
you guys think that I should have done
better really maybe just developing my
pieces more early yeah I think when you
went for the rook lift it was a little
bit short-sighted so it seems like a
good idea cuz you have a direct threat
but since white can really block it away
it would have been better if you just
continued trying to develop your pieces
yeah I agree I think that I think that
this is it's a really hard thing to not
want to go for it cuz you see the
potential of it right and when you see
the potential of it like it becomes
enticing but unless there's something
concrete you're kind of you're kind of
seeing ghosts a little bit cuz like
hutch said right he was just
double-checking that he wasn't getting
mated and once he did how many moves are
you from a real threat it's like 1 2
then you gotta bring the Queen over then
you have your whole idea it's just it's
too much to really think you're gonna
get anything probably would have been
better to you know start the bishop
maneuver now maybe bring the bishop
around or even play Knight to d7 you
know to try to prevent hutch from
playing 95 so that you can go back back
to this idea I think I think rook f6 was
just a little bit too ambitious but
otherwise you played played very well
mm-hm
thank you appreciate it I this is this
has been great I don't even know what
you guys feel about it this whole chess
thing right here between us this is
working this is working here right I'm
glad I came into the metas on Twitch
like I've always watched I never played
chess really ever but I you know I enjoy
watching it you know it's me and you
both I don't like it I don't know how I
got here I was always over concern when
when when you would ask me to do like
just calm collaborations and stuff
because I I thought most of your
audience would probably not want to hear
chess tips from like a fifteen hundred
Raider player 1400 player then in this
tournament it's a little bit now I feel
like there's a ton of pressure on me
because there's actually an expectation
to perform well so I was actually glad
you said that you brought that up cuz
for yeah so just so you know so hutch
and I were doing chef screams like five
six years ago right and I actually asked
him to start doing a show where he would
just do a show and talk to like see now
you know you could have been coaching a
lot of chess people hutch and you didn't
take me up on that I mean I give like
beginners tips but I don't I don't
that's all I'm qualified to give ya but
guys this has been great I don't think
the question Alexandra any parting words
for these guys before we let him go I
think you guys were the match if I was
most excited for today because hutch is
such a heavy favorite
but Yasuo has been improving so quickly
so I was having so much fun watching you
guys both played well and good luck in
the future tournament guys appreciate it
have a good run thanks guys bye yep I
agree it was a matchup we were looking
forward to and I didn't really
disappoint hutch played well so did
Yasuo and honestly that guy's that guys
uh if you had to start picking someone
early who might win the consolation
Brett I don't know if Yasuo was gonna
have it to make it to the next realm but
he's that guy's clearly not 800 talked
about a sleeper right yeah exactly I
mean I even wonder all right I shouldn't
say this but too late in terms of
strategy if he goes for the consolation
bracket he has pretty good chances to
win it all versus if he tries to go to
the championship Brera bracket and then
he has to face like boy boy and hutch
and who else is gonna be in there box
box
well XQ see obviously is the guy who has
a chance to pass Yasuo right he's got to
win that next game um his next matchup
versus moist most critical just gonna
say it like that
and is a critic Cowell I put the wrong
emphasis on the right Salah but I don't
know it doesn't matter let's talk about
the schedule
Alexandra who's coming up tomorrow
alright let's let's take a look here so
we are the 8th Danny that's a reminder
for you just because you know I know
dates have been confusing thank you
thank you yes no so tomorrow we're gonna
have Papa platta versus Ludwig that's
one that is gonna be very close and
rating I'm really looking forward to it
a little weak has been a riot in the
interviews we also have xqc versus moist
critical so that is some pretty big
names both on Twitch and on YouTube what
a
there I just need a little poem and that
will be a little scary after yeah we uh
we've had a ton of fun today remind
everybody to hit that follow button if
somehow you're you're just tuning into
chess on Twitch it is a real thing it
does exist and it's not going anywhere
for a while so please I hit that follow
button you can also follow us on
youtube.com slash chess and pretty much
anywhere slash chess exists so make sure
you give that a follow and Alexandra and
I will we'll be back
we've got lots going on in the channel
we also have the speech test
Championship Grand Prix that's foreign
language to maybe some people just
tuning into chess but huge event were
running here on chess comm so if you're
in for some chef's early on tomorrow you
can check that out as well
Alexandra I think it's time we let
people go party like rock stars or maybe
maybe not a rock star maybe a mountain
dew G fuel what a way to end thanks
Danny it's been fun doing commentary
with you chat hopefully we'll see you
back tomorrow bye everybody